Welcome back this is going to be my new marvel
spider-man 3 movie video we have some videos of
the set of them filming scenes so we'll break
it all down there were also some reports of them
filming in some new spider-man suits so i'll
try to explain that as well because this also
kind of connects back to what's happening
with Wandavision in doctor strange too
there's even some avengers easter eggs in this
too so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos they're
going to be filming the movie for a while so
there'll be a lot more footage that we'll see
before we actually get a real legit trailer
we're doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just post all your biggest theories about
spider-man 3 on the video this is that set video
that the daily mail just posted of tom holland
filming his peter parker and spider-man scenes
so you notice in the video that the daily mail
posted the scenes are all taking place during
the christmas holiday as you can see so spider-man
3 confirmed to be a christmas movie just like iron
man 3 even though technically iron man 3 was not
released during the actual real-life christmas
holiday i'm assuming that they always plan to
do it this way for spider-man 3. originally it
was actually going to be a summer movie i don't
know that they changed that just because they
delayed the movie till christmas they might
have always planned for it to be christmas
during the events of the movie just because of
the way the marvel phase 4 timeline is happening
and even though it's christmas during this scene
it's hard to tell if the entire movie is going to
take place during the christmas holiday or if
they're gonna jump around in time like they've
done during previous spider-man movies like when
mysterio is explaining his backstory during far
from home they flash back to a long time ago
during the events of captain america civil
war so there might be events like that during
the film but these scenes are of tom holland
as regular peter parker walking down the street
there weren't any street signs or intersections
that people reported so no idea which part of
manhattan this is but he's walking down the street
to go have coffee at the donut shop the bakery
that mj and supposedly ned leeds are working at
and it's called get it peter pan donut and pastry
shop very apropos a peter parker someone reported
that ned lee's was also working at the bake shop
with mj when he walked in to have coffee with him
but i didn't see him in any of the footage so i
couldn't tell if he was also wearing one of those
bake shop uniforms like mj is wearing so he could
have just also been meeting them there for coffee
mj could be working there and going to school at
the same time if this is the christmas holiday
period they'd be out of school anyway on break
and they're getting pretty close to graduation
they had to repeat their most recent year after
the snap that was the whole joke of the blip in
spider-man far from home but this could wind up
being the middle of their senior year and they
could just do the tobey maguire spider-man thing
where you see them doing regular jobs outside
of school during those movies mary jane had all
manner of odd jobs but they did have the time jump
in that first toby spider-man movie but i'm not
expecting any giant time jumps during spider-man 3
in that same way most of the mcu movies with the
exception of avengers end game because of that
5-year time jump don't have a ton of huge time
jumps like the first toby film Wandavision is
currently the first marvel phase 4 project set
after spider-man far from home forward in the
timeline moving things forward and during episode
1 it was revealed that it's august 23rd 2023 even
though they're doing that weird thing where they
jump through the sitcom decades and it seems like
time is moving in a really strange way it's still
set right after the events of spider-man far from
home in august so spider-man 3 taking place after
that obviously could be in december 2023 within
the world of the mcu or 2024 at the latest they
did delay the release of the movie a little bit
because of the virus delays but it was always
supposed to come out this year so the timeline
probably hasn't changed that much for marvel phase
four the other big question that this scene with
peter parker raises is that he's walking around in
broad daylight as peter parker after getting doxed
by mysterio so if he's doing this and he isn't
being bum rushed by a bunch of new york city cops
trying to tackle him in the street it implies that
it's after they fixed the mysterio problem and
clear his name there's no way of knowing when that
happens during the movie but there's some other
easter eggs that they spotted in separate scenes
that i'll talk about in a second that reference
the quote-unquote save spidey movement so that
is a thing during the actual plot of the film but
something tells me that the mysterio the doxing
clearing his name won't be the biggest part of the
movie most of the attention will probably be on
all the sinister six stuff it seems like they're
setting up in the background the spider-verse
the multiverse easter eggs like what's going on
with dr octopus and electro what's going on with
the doctor strange subplot the other mysterio
easter eggs the safe spidey easter eggs avengers
infinity war snap easter eggs you see all over
this message board with the posters some of this
also seems like it ties in with what's happening
on Wandavision and what's going to be happening
during doctor strange 2 because doctor strange
2 is coming out right after spider-man 3 and he's
going to be a big character during spider-man 3.
so you see these avengers infinity war references
on the board this one says we remember with the
snapped person disappearing on it another picture
says the snap cannot something it's covered up a
little bit then there's the conspiracy theory
poster for mysterio saying i believe that might
have something to do with his larger story that he
told about the multiverse the elementals being a
warrior from another planet there's a poster that
says citizens to defend spidey which seems like a
direct response to mysterio's fake video like some
people probably believe it's fake from the start
and some believe it's true so spider-man seems
like he has his own fan club developing already
and i just posted a video about charlie cox and
daredevil during spider-man 3 because they were
all the reports that he had just finished filming
scenes on the movie and i know a lot of people are
hoping that he winds up helping spider-man as a
lawyer so this citizens to defend spidey could
have something to do with that as well there's
a whole bunch of missing persons posters all
over this like missing children something about
someone missing their babies this kind of seems
like it's both a reference to avengers end game
in the snap and the Wandavision stuff with her
new twin children from the comics wiccan and speed
during the first couple of episodes of wandavision
i believe it was during Wandavision episode 2 they
kept chanting for the children they were putting
on this special play in the neighborhood the
special magic act for the children quote unquote
even though there were almost no children in the
neighborhood until wanda got pregnant like why are
we doing all this for the children if there are
no children inside this weird alternate dimension
those little boys and girls are counting on us
all of this is for the children for the children
there are a lot of theories that people have
about what's going on with that children's
subplot mephisto because he was such a big part
of that in the comics i'll talk about that during
my wanda vision videos without more episodes
of wandavision and more easter eggs it's kind
of hard to tell how this connects to that but
the director of Wandavision said that he was
working with the director of spider-man 3 john
watts because Wandavision is supposed to help
set up spider-man 3 in addition to doctor strange
too probably through the spider-verse multiverse
subplot because that seems like one of the
things that all three of these productions have
in common the multiverse story arc that they're
setting up in Wandavision for marvel phase four
the other scenes that we got a look at were of tom
holland filming scenes in his spider-man costumes
and it was him in the now old spider-man far
from home steve ditko looking suit on the street
fans that were at the set claim that they were
filming in multiple different spider-man suits
for these scenes but it's hard to tell if that's
because peter parker upgrades the steve ditko suit
or changes it somehow or if the other suit looked
different just because it was designed to be used
differently when they were filming certain types
of scenes and really it's just the exact same suit
i think one of the easiest predictions that you
can make about this movie is that he will get a
new version of the spider-man suit somehow during
the film it's a staple of all superhero movies
that there's always a new costume in sequels and
if you're someone like iron man you get multiple
new suits in your sequel movies it's just one
of the easy slam dunk ways they use to boost
toy sales by writing those extra suits into the
story like oh i got to buy another toy now but so
far i haven't seen any reports about what this
newest suit might wind up being i think we're
all assuming it'll be a little closer to classic
spider-man because the whole arc of his spider-man
character during these new marvel movies is that
he's becoming his own man making his own suits
so wouldn't the next version of the suit be a
much more classic version of the homemade suit
what's going to be happening this week though is
we'll get Wandavision episode 3 my video for that
we'll post on friday i'm expecting to see more of
them explaining what's actually going on in more
of this multiverse plot so we'll get some more
clues about what might actually be going on with
the multiverse during marvel phase 4. there were
also some more reports about characters showing
up during thor 4 love and thunder so i might do
a new thor video this week as well but everyone
post all your theories about what's going on
during spider-man 3 in the comments below just
based on all this new footage they'll be filming
the movie all the way up to march so hopefully
we'll get some more reports about what's actually
going on and some of the stuff that they're doing
congratulations dexter thielhelm you're the
giveaway winner for my last big spider-man video
please email me on the about page of my channel so
i can get your contact details everyone click here
for that spider-man 3 daredevil video and click
here for my full wandavision episode 1 and episode
2 videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next video!